so when you think of the Mainframe what
do you think old expensive outdated
maybe you think about those movies with
the tapes spinning vacuum tubes even
worse well to give me just five minutes
and let me tell you the reality of the
Mainframe today so let's start with
these myths the first myth we think
about is old
and old systems well the reality the
reality is today we have the latest
telum processor the telom processor
provides the ability to take 40
approximate Linux systems and run them
on one telom chip in addition to that it
has a built-in AI processor and separate
i o processing which allows you to
process much faster from data access
standpoint so I can do that high
transaction processing
now think about that transaction come in
about 40 to 1. well that goes to the
next one expensive if we think about
expensive
and we think the Mainframe is expensive
if I can already consolidate 40 to 1
that's already impressive but we care a
lot about sustainability today as well
so let's think about it we can take 75
percent less energy usage 75 percent
less energy usage in using the system
and 67 percent less space in my data
center by using Z boxes
significantly improves my sustainability
message while I can still do large
transaction processing and just for
another small comparison in the same
time Google can process 60 000
transactions Aziz running 2 million
transactions think about that now the
next problem that always comes up is
skills if you think about skills and the
use of skills what skills do I need do
you think I have to use that 3270 green
screen you might show on some movies
still well no you can use all the modern
tools that we have in the environment
modern SCM of git vs code python
infrastructure is code all the current
Concepts all the current processes and
you can interact with the system and all
the modern languages I already said
python one of the most common languages
people like to use today not only for
infrastructure for scripting for just
General application development but also
Java node go and all the traditional
languages that we have in Z so I can do
and work with it in the same way
and
let's think about Cloud everybody's
trying to look at Cloud today and talk
about Cloud native
well when we think about the Mainframe
machine it can run openshift
and if we think about open shift in
environment that's what people are
looking at for their Cloud native
applications building containers and
providing Linux environments all of that
is available natively with a z platform
in addition to the zos environment which
allows you to run those High transaction
throughput guaranteed reliability
transactions you need today
so it really we need to look at hybrid
Cloud not just Cloud you're not going to
run in one Cloud you're going to run in
multiple clouds and you're going to run
on-prem that combination including z
provides the best capabilities for your
business today
now
hopefully I've convinced you but if I
haven't
then go try it yourself go to IBM cloud
and you know how you can get Intel today
well go pick a z processor and go play
with Linux on Z or zos and try it out
yourself and see that it's really the
modern machine that it is today
thanks for watching if you like this
video and would like to see more videos
like this just click like And subscribe